and we totally sneaked into the Playboy
Mansion because we were wild like that
yeah my mom was like passed out and
didn't know and it was just like it was
a lot of fun yeah
well you saw you you were bulimic I was
bulimic yeah how old were you
nine maybe nine I think yeah my dad
would call me fat and like you know say
like you know that Park a commercial and
like I can't believe it's not butter
he was like parquet or call me Bertha
cuz I broke the toilet seat and he was
just like he would be really mean to me
was he being mean or just trying to be
funny
no he was he shoved my sister's face and
dog food and gave her like issues - yeah
he just you know I don't think you had
good parenting skills so that's where
all my issues stem from okay everyone
everyone know everyone has the same
reaction I'm sorry let's backtrack a
little bit how do you think I'm funny
David normal [ __ ] aren't funny
no there's nothing funny about normal
[ __ ] a hundred I'm sorry you said
your dad do you need a water
[ __ ] your sister's face in [ __ ] dog
food what cuz she wet the bed how does
that even how does that what called
abuse it's [ __ ] up yeah it's about my
mom like left and because of all of that
and yeah it was crazy it was a wild
situation I was five so he would you
would like poke fun at your weight all
the time yeah and so I started to throw
up because I wanted him to love me and I
thought like you know I could be skinny
this way I don't know where I was
introduced to that idea I still baffles
me that I don't remember but I just I
was throw up you know when you guys were
on the the when you were on dr. Phil
then he was already gone out of your
life well my dad he'd like you know he's
a dad that makes the appearances so like
we would see him for we'd get two weeks
during the summer and then that was it
and usually we would only last a week
because my stepmother was so awful and
we'd always get put to work on her
horses or something else like it was
like a long is it mandatory for you to
see your father or is that something
that you guys wanted when we were 4 2014
I could like decide to not see how I
decided not to yeah so that was pretty
much it but now I mean we're as good as
you can be my dad you know I have to
love him from a distance it's very it's
someone that you can't get deep with
it's very surface it's
he is a narcissist and um you know
everyone's got personnel there's one in
100 people that have a personality
disorder actually one in five with
mental illness one in a hundred that
have a psychological disorder where you
could be a psychopath a sociopath
you know cluster B or a or C uh in the
dsm-5 ooh hey a lot of [ __ ] I don't know
how you like saying all this way so
you're I mean that's so hard because
like I think as an adult I mean you know
maybe it's like a coping mechanism for
us when we get old and we're like that
person that treated me like [ __ ] is like
that because something that happened to
him he wasn't given the skills to be a
good dad you know his parents weren't
great examples and he just you know they
were great at business and that was it
and he's a great businessman you know
but that's about it
that's where it ends yeah he's not
generous because he's a great
businessman can't be he doesn't know how
to be a dad so I've come to a place of
acceptance with that and it's hard the
only thing is hard for me it's like I'll
get a text message for my stepmom and
she's like oh my gosh can you believe
we've been married 10 years I don't
really know her that well either but I
love the Christmas cards where she acts
like she yeah but it's all for show you
know like I just like to show that they
are doing well and stuff and so and
that's why I'm very honest and upfront
and open about all my problems because I
don't like to pretend that I'm this
happy-go-lucky [ __ ] I'm like no
actually this is what's happening with
me and if something recent happens like
what I told you earlier
yeah I'm not ready to talk about it till
I process [ __ ] yeah cuz it's so fresh
like you need a minute so like you got
to keep things personal for you to deal
with the first before you do and you
don't have to say everything I know that
we do not know in there and there's like
a certain loyalty you feel like with
your audience that you need to share
everything but when you're not ready to
talk about something you talk about it
and we're talking about something that I
wanna talk about so how did you how did
you kind of like kick the whole bulimia
thing I got lipo which this [ __ ]
is hilarious did before that funny dude
yeah
ever heard somebody beat a mental
disorder so how did you defeat this
mental disorder liposuction baby no but
I was really commit I'd everything I
could under the Sun like before that I
tried dieting I tried eating I spent all
my money on trainers because I would put
any of my money towards anything that I
thought you know and I'd go broke you
know just to be skinny to me by that
dream and nothing worked and so when I
got married my gift was the liposuction
and that's the only thing that was worth
it oh my god how much is a liposuction
procedure it was really good car it was
really expensive I don't even remember
the exact numbers but it was a lot yeah
still that pricey well I got laser lipo
and in the traditional lipo and then I
did these um I went in a hyperbaric
chamber before and after so it basically
oxygenates your blood and it's really
cool um and it helps with recovery and I
also stayed in an aftercare facility
because I was a bloody mess so the whole
process was like the true did just for
the lipo I don't know but it was worth
every penny
it changed the whole shape of my body
and it gave me that mental confidence
that I always wanted because this
business tears you apart you know you
gained five pounds as a woman or ten it
shows on camera because the camera adds
ten pounds and people are ruthless you
have the recipe for disaster to be in a
business that tears you apart mentally I
know it's like but you love it
I don't honestly I might take a break
from it for a little bit because I don't
love it I'm not I haven't been
auditioning I've been going out I don't
have an agent I don't have a manager
I've been a free bird since the summer
and I should have less you - well it's
not it wasn't really like I decided to
leave because it just became an
unhealthy work environment because I was
dealing with a lot of [ __ ] with my
ex-husband still the last court date I
had was in June and I got an audition
for SNL and I [ __ ] nailed it but then
I also did my first live show and then
there was some unfortunately and I hate
to like err [ __ ] out right now but I we
both decided it was time for us to not
work for with each other but what made
what hurt my heart and I've never told
this story before
was that she thought I wanted security
because I thought I sold out the show
and I was this hot [ __ ] but really any
time I do a live show I want to talk
because of what I did my first and she
didn't think that I could book a
stand-up show or do a stand-up show and
I ended up doing it and in February of
2019 the person that I was working with
okay I did it anyway I did the stand-up
show and then for the live show I wanted
to have my security just to be like safe
and know who was you know coming in
because I'm always scared of my
ex-husband or someone it's gonna like
come to the shows that's always a fear
of mine when I do something live you
don't know my fans can be very grabby
and so she thought that I was hot [ __ ]
that I thought too highly myself and it
was like wow I can't believe you think
that I mean when it's like coming from a
place of trying to feel safe yeah yeah
yeah it's interesting how people
perceive you and it's it's good that I
like knew that and I'm smart enough to
like pay attention to that because you
don't want someone that's working for
you that thinks that you think that
you're hot [ __ ] or too good for whatever
like and they don't know where you're
coming from